Welcome to Nestalgia!
And this is the inaugural episode of Nestalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
Today's game, 10-yard fight!
But first, we should talk about who we are!
No, no, no, you can't, you got it, I can't start this.
That is a perfect introduction to, uh, Sean.
So, I'm Mike Esposito, I'm a producer over at Nickelodeon, but I love Nintendo, probably since I was about 4 years old when we got a Nintendo 64.
So that outdates me, and clearly indicates that we are by no means NES experts.
Instead, we are people who are really interested in video games in general, and wanted to explore the NES in order of release.
I'm Joe, and I'm an aspiring writer, and Mike was pretty dead on with what I am too, as far as my video game experience.
I grew up with my Nintendo, but I'm, uh, not an NES expert.
What's up, I'm Sam Smith, uh, no relation to the artist, and I'm, uh, I'm a PA at Nickelodeon.
I grew up with an N64 for a while before I got anything else, so I kinda, I got a lot of nostalgia for that.
Never played NES before, uh, really before this, so this is kind of a, this is gonna be a good time.
And I'm Sean.
You do not get to know where I work.
I started everything with the Super Nintendo, then I kind of abandoned Nintendo for a while and stuck with PlayStation, Xbox, all that fun stuff, until, uh, recently.
So I'm looking forward to playing most of these NES games for the first time.
Guys, this, this is not gonna work.
What? This whole idea of remastering all of our episodes.
We recorded so many episodes, we can't just jump back to the first one.
Yeah. Yeah, I don't even remember what I was like back then.
Yeah, this is a different person.
I don't, I don't talk like this anymore.
Yeah. What did I mean, Mike was pretty dead on with what I am too?
What am I talking about?
Right, I think about that with all of this.
We're looking at a script here, and I just realized, how did anybody listen to the second episode after hearing this?
They're good people.
But, you know, we gotta, we gotta do something, right?
Well, what if, so whenever I'm watching like a movie or something, I love watching the audio commentary of the creators.
What if we just do audio commentary over our original episode?
Are you worried that they'll be able to even understand what we're saying as we talk?
It works for movies.
Yeah. You know what?
I'm in. Let's do it.
Welcome to Nostalgia.
Nostalgia. All right, and guys, this is it.
Joining me are Sean and Joe for the audio commentary on the very first episode of Nostalgia.
Hi, I'm Joe.
I play Joe. It was recorded back in February of 2018.
And this is the enormous episode of Nostalgia.
Right, yeah. Sam does the song, and I think we've mentioned that a few times, but that was not like, he didn't, he already had that song, but didn't know what it was gonna be used for.
Wow. I didn't know that.
I thought it was Bespoke.
Yeah. Very Nostalgia.
Yeah, he was making a bunch of stuff, and clearly, if you want Bespoke, that's us on this episode.
We have no idea what we're talking about.
It's all ad-libbed.
There was a microphone in the center of a table that we all just kind of gathered around.
Yeah. Oh, here's the part. I'm about to talk.
I remember when I said this.
He said his name.
I was the first time I really said much on there.
That was your last name. Yeah, that's true.
And, you know, I don't really know what I was talking about.
I was a little nervous. I'm not gonna lie.
I think we were all a little nervous.
Yeah. We didn't know what we were doing.
We had only tried to record a podcast once, and to hear Sam talking now, like, he's really
into the N64.
Yeah, and keep in mind, Sam was on the show every episode when this started.
He was on the show. That's true.
And before he said the no relation to the artist, I didn't know that he wasn't the artist.
I thought he was the artist Sam Smith. I thought that was Sam Smith, yeah.
Yeah. I knew he wasn't Sam Smith, but I didn't know that he wasn't related to Sam Smith.
Yeah. I just assumed that all Sam Smiths are related.
Like cousins, like your body is a wonderland sort of stuff.
I did that on Facebook back in like when I was like 15 or 16.
I friended every other Mike Esposito and just thought like that would be so funny.
So funny. And they were all really rude to me.
You know, our audio producer Chris did the same thing.
To all Michael Espositos?
No, no, to all Chris's.
I won't say his last name.
I don't know if he wants it out there.
Just kind of getting into the NES launch.
Do you guys notice how fast we're talking in this episode?
I don't. You mean in the audio commentary or in the episode we're commenting on?
In the episode we're commentating on, in the very first episode, I feel like maybe it's a bit of jitters or whatever, but I feel like we're rushing through even this information on the NES right now.
Do you think we could like maybe time stretch from here?
Like just slow it all down so we could actually comment on what everything, like what everyone's saying?
Like maybe like comment on what we might have been thinking when we were saying it?
So you want me to remaster the first episode, like the thing we just tried to do?
Ugh. You're right.
Listen. Yes.
No, no.
You know what? This is stupid.
This commentary thing isn't working either.
Nobody, you think anybody's still listening to this thing?
We're talking over us talking about things that just don't make sense.
We're giving, we're, why don't we, why don't we just take this commentary, take the file
and we'll do commentary over it.
I'm like, okay, this is why we thought this would work.
I think that's a great idea.
I think, you know what it actually is?
I just don't think we're interesting as hosts.
We sucked as hosts back then.
We kind of suck at doing this commentary thing.
I think we just need new hosts for nostalgia.
If we, if we just start over with new hosts and you know, we can direct them and they
could save our stuff or whatever.
If we get new people, they'll do this right.
I think that's a good idea.
I hate me. Yeah.
I like where your energy's at.
Yeah. I like where your head's at.
I think this needs a new energy, you know, for a new generation.
All right, let's do that.
Welcome to Nostalgia.
Nostalgia. And this is the inaugural episode of Nostalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game
released in North America.
Today's game, Ten Yard Fight.
But first, we should talk about who we are.
Oh, no, no. You got it.
I can't start this.
That's a perfect introduction to us, Sean.
So I'm Mike Esposito.
I'm a producer over at Nickelodeon, but I love Nintendo probably since I was about four
years old when we got a Nintendo 64.
So that outdates me and clearly indicates that we are by no means NES experts.
Instead, we are people who are really interested in video games in general and wanted to explore
the NES in order of release.
I'm Jo and I'm an aspiring writer.
And Mike was pretty dead on with what I am too.
As far as my video game experience, I grew up with my Nintendo, but I'm not really an
NES expert.
And I'm Sean. You do not get to know where I work.
I started everything with the Super Nintendo.
Then I kind of abandoned Nintendo for a while and stuck with PlayStation, Xbox, all that fun
stuff until recently.
So I'm looking forward to playing most of these NES games for the first time.
Let's jump right into our first game.
The game that this episode is all about, Ten Yard Fight.
I don't think it really needs any introduction.
It's a football game that is pretty bare bones, but let's get some initial impressions.
Sean? What? Well, it's not Madden.
But it's definitely football.
I enjoyed it from the get-go.
To be honest, it was very frustrating.
But I'd say my initial impression was positive.
So yeah, my initial impression was also positive, but it's not the kind of game that's generally
my type of game.
Not a big sports game kind of guy.
I'm also a little skewed at the beginning when I start playing a game.
I'm also interested in how they made it work with the limitations and how, you know.
So it was, I mean, I thought it was well done at first.
No, no, no.
This isn't working because they're still reading our old material.
These hosts are amazing and they sound way better than us, but it's just, it's our old
material. It's enough revisiting the old nostalgia.
We need to start over.
Mike, we've recorded like 250 something episodes already.
I don't know if, like, do we want to do this?
I think it's for the best that we just start over.
The show has sucked every single week.
Look, we're not even halfway through anyways.
So really it's not going to make much of a difference that we start over.
Right. And by starting over too, you know, we'll have all the knowledge, but the listeners won't
know that because we're just going to pretend like we never did the show.
We didn't have that many listeners anyway.
So by starting over, yeah, it's going to be tough to fake it a little bit, but we'll be
able to like, we'll be more knowledgeable.
Think about the monetization option, like strategies that we could do now that we've done this
before. Right.
We can introduce the Patreon right away.
Oh man. Millionaires.
I think it's a good idea.
My question to you guys though, 10 yard fight.
Can you pretend like you've never played it before?
When was the last time you played 10 yard fight?
When did we first play 10 yard fight?
Yeah. I could prove, I feel like I can pretty easily pretend I never played a 10 yard fight.
It doesn't, uh, it doesn't hold a special place in my heart.
Okay. So look, we're going to start the episode over this time, not remastering, but remaking 10
yard fight. And we're going to have all of our knowledge, but the listeners won't.
It's going to be great. Okay.
Let's do it. 10 yard fight.
You're the quarterback in this amazingly real football game.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike.
I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe.
And we'll be your three hosts through, uh, the NES chronological exploration.
Uh, don't ask why we chose North American games.
Uh, we're from North America.
That's about all the information I'm willing to give today.
What about you guys? I will give our listeners my social security number if they ask me kindly enough, you know,
but, uh, yeah, like I'm, I'm also North American.
Yes. We're all North American confirmed.
And we don't know anything about the NES.
And that's like the most interesting part about this show is that we're not playing these
games with all of that, uh, nostalgia, if you will, we're playing these, we're playing
these with people who have nostalgia.
And that's where we got the name of the show.
And we're going to play these games in order.
And believe it or not, the very first game is 10 yard fight.
So rather than give you the whole history on the NES, like some other stupid podcast would,
we're going to focus on just the games one at a time.
Sean, Joe, 10 yard fight.
It's our, it's our very first NES game.
You know, absolutely nothing about eight bit video games, right?
The first I've ever played.
Yeah. Like it's the eighties and we barely even have computers.
Like how did they do this?
It's so cool.
And like, why did they start with football?
I love it. It's so cool.
Yeah. It's this, this especially different just from like, not having seen this type of game
before from this era.
Like I've never played a game that this old before.
And I, and I am honestly, I'm clue clue for Gaga over this.
Absolutely. Um, I think they might have gotten like the rules of football a little wrong though.
Like, uh, the, the first thing you see is like in the kickoff, you, you start off in this
like really weird, like square formation that never forms in football college or professional.
And then the, the, you start like marching to a drum beat up the field.
And like, I don't know where these drums are coming from.
It's not like we're at like a Notre Dame game.
Yeah. The drum, the drum beat marching thing is a little strange, but Sean, this game has a
feature that I don't even think modern Madden games have.
And that is that it shows you on the right hand side of your screen.
It shows you where you are at all times across the entire 100 yard football field.
And I find that information really useful.
Yeah. You know why, uh, the, yeah, you don't need that in any other game is because it just,
you just see where you are in the football field.
Yeah. I was going to say without the, without the little like meter on the side, how do you know
what you're looking at?
That's actually in this is a little tidbit about real football.
Uh, if you see, there's like little, uh, arm bands that kind of look like a utility
gloves, uh, that a quarterback wears that really is only just to tell them where they
are on the field. And Sean, you're our like football guy.
You're our expert here.
Sean's a big Buffalo bills fan.
If you guys didn't know go bills.
Now it's interesting.
They, the, the characters that you play as they are in bills uniforms.
That's that's true.
You do play as the Buffalo bills.
It's a little known fact. They didn't get like the licensing agreement.
So they can't say it's the Buffalo bills, but like this was 1985 or something.
And the bills were terrible, but they knew in like five to eight years that they'd be
just going to super bowls all the time.
So they wanted to get ahead of, you know, you get ahead of the curve in terms of
popularity. Yeah. And let's be honest.
The bills colors are main character colors.
Primary red and blue.
Absolutely. Superman characters.
America. Is there a team with pink and purple jerseys at all?
There's purple.
No pink though.
These might just be like the Vikings on like a quiet, like peaceful.
I just want to go take a nap day.
What's great about this podcast, other than it being so fresh and original and inspired
is that this is just one of the 672 more NES games that we are going to play on this
podcast. I genuinely can't wait to.
Yeah. Which is, yeah, that it's great that we have that large of a library and I look forward
to covering each of them in depth.
Sean. I just, I look, I, I don't know if we could do this.
Like we just, we are, we had so much progress before and like, it's going to take us.
What are you talking about? Guys.
Just step out for a second.
I can't take us like 13 years, 13 years.
It's going to be 20, 20, 20, 36.
We're going to be entering or leaving middle age or I don't know if we can do this guys.
Yeah. Oh, we can still do this.
We just need to start earlier so that we can finish sooner.
What do you mean?
I'm going to go back in time to 1994 and recruit kid Sean and kid Joe onto nostalgia.
And start the podcast.
That way it can be done in 2006, just in time for the launch of the Wii.
And we can have Wii-stalgia.
That's perfect. I, at this point, I don't see why not.
I wasn't busy in 1994.
So yeah. Okay.
I'm sure I can find you guys at your exact locations.
Talk to your parents, get entrance inside your house and pitch you the idea.
It shouldn't be a problem.
Yeah. Let's do it.
Okay. I made it.
And it's January 30th, 1994.
Okay. That's not ideal.
Sean's not going to be in a great mood, but he's a kid.
Kids get over things quick.
So, uh, let me, let me, oh, this house looks good.
Hey, hey, Sean.
Who are you?
Who? That's not important right now.
Um, but we're like really good friends in the future.
Like, like Jim Kelly and Thurman Thomas.
Oh, yeah.
Um, those legendary, uh, I'm sorry, those current Buffalo Bills players.
Uh, yeah. I mean, you know, they'll get them next year, right?
Fifth time's a charm.
I hope so.
Look, I know you're really upset about the whole Bills losing four Super Bowls in a row
and everything like that, but I've got just the thing that will cheer you up.
Is it candy?
Eh, no, not even, not even close, actually.
You're, you should stick, you should stay away from guessing and specifically guessing
what video games are about based on titles.
Anyway. Yeah.
I know. Not a great joke for right now.
Uh, you're not in a jokey mood, but you know what?
The thing that's going to cheer you up, a podcast where we play all the Nintendo Entertainment
System games in chronological order.
Oh, what's a chrono?
Sir, what?
Nintendo? We're going to play all video games that were released on the Nintendo Entertainment System,
but we're just going to play them in the order they were released.
So you, me, and another kid named Joe, we're all going to play and we're going to host
this podcast. It's going to be great.
I don't like Joe Namath.
No, no, no, not Joe Namath.
Uh, Joe, Joe.
Who are you?
Listen, kid.
There's going to be a lot you don't understand, especially as you get older.
Things are always going to be weird.
But right now. Hold on.
Don't you like the idea of playing video games?
I like video games.
That's great.
So we're just going to play all of the Nintendo Entertainment System games in chronological
order and also record them for a podcast.
It's only going to take 13 years and will be done by 2006.
Okay.
I like that.
What's a Nintendo?
Oh.
Who are you people?
Hey, look, I don't have much time before they realize I'm gone.
Look, I'm your friend from the future.
And there's a problem with your future.
Okay. Just, just listen to me.
Okay. One day you're going to be on a podcast about the NES.
Okay. And on January 15th, 2021, when you get to episode 154, you have to remember that Zelda 2 is an
essential game. I don't know what sort of trauma you went through to give you such a stupid opinion, but it is
not an inessential game.
It's essential. No.
Look, listen, kid, your life goes downhill after that vote because of how wrong you are.
You have to listen to me. I have to go.
Oh, just remember, Sean, Zelda 2, essential game.
Wait, I can't stop here.
This is Donkey Kong Country.
All right. Well, it shouldn't be that hard to find Donkey Kong.
I'm sure he's right around.
Wow. That's awfully convenient.
Hey, Donkey Kong.
Great games.
Oh, you didn't make the games in this one.
Um, big fan of donkeys.
It's not a donkey.
Okay. All right. Um, look, you ever see the movie King Kong?
Yeah. King.
What do you mean? You don't know what I'm talking about?
Big gorilla, just like you, goes to New York City, stomps all over the place, climbs the
Empire State. Not ringing a bell.
Okay. So I've traveled to a universe where the film King Kong was never made.
And thus I can't get Donkey Kong to attack the Brooklyn construction site to form Nintendo.
Wow. This time travel stuff is a lot more complicated than they make it out to be.
Hey, Donkey Kong, one more question.
Are you actually Donkey Kong, Donkey Kong Jr., or Cranky Kong?
That's what I thought.
Uh, Joe, where were you?
Uh, no, I just had to, I had to step out to him.
I just had to, hey, uh, what's the status of Zelda 2 on the essential games list?
It's on there, right? Joe?
Uh, the, I don't know what you're bringing that up for, but I really don't like talking
about Zelda 2, um, unless it's for the podcast.
I, something happened and it just makes me really upset.
So, please don't.
Wait, what do you mean something happened?
Guys, I'm back.
Hey! What happened? It's not gonna work, okay?
This whole, like, time travel or dimension hopping, I don't even, it's not even clear
which one I was doing, to be honest.
It's just not working, and, you know, I feel like, instead of doing Nostalgia as a show,
or trying to do it earlier, or trying to rework it, we should just do a whole new podcast.
Something that we've never covered before.
I'm so relieved, because I've been really getting sick of this.
Yeah, I've been thinking, like, we've been, we gave it the good several hundred hour test
run, it's not working, let's, let's cut our losses.
Right, and so I'm thinking, the problem with Nostalgia was that the scope was just too singular,
you know, it was, video games are already a pretty niche topic.
Not too many people play video games, and then on top of that, yeah, on top of that,
not that many people play old video games, old video games that nobody even, Nintendo
won't even sell them to you anymore.
We can't get the Gen Z's on this like that.
Right, so I'm thinking we really broaden the scope to the most broad thing I could think
about. Tick tock.
No, no, no, don't worry, you'll see.
Let's do it. And welcome to Alphapedia, a alphabetical exploration of every Wikipedia article in the internet.
I'm Mike.
I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe.
Guys, welcome to the inaugural episode of Alphapedia.
Today, we will be doing the very first article in alphabetical order of Wikipedia, that famous
website. Believe it or not, a bit of a shocker, it's just the letter A by itself.
You know, that's actually kind of surprising to me.
I figured there'd be, like, maybe zero would be before A.
Like, you know, this is just a
new way of looking at things.
But I said alphabetical exploration, not alphanumerical.
So we're not covering numbers.
We're not going to cover numbers ever on this show.
Okay. Because numbers would be things like, you know, 8, 16, 32, 64, like, you know, we don't talk
about that kind of stuff on this show.
13. 14. All right.
Yeah, fine.
Um, what's your favorite thing about the letter A, Mike?
My favorite thing about the letter A is that if you go back far enough, the letter A is
actually just kind of like a deer or a bull.
Uh, now is this in, see, cause I, I have, I only have an A in my middle name, so I'm
moderately familiar with A, but not like super familiar.
So like when I think of it, I'm not sure what you're talking about with deer or bull.
I think of like Apple or airplane or a nightmare on Elm street for the NES.
Right. Yeah.
Well, I'm, I'm talking about the actual shape of the letter A, which started, you know,
the A that we know it today is really only since like the three hundreds.
You see the A actually was kind of like a K, uh, going back a little bit.
And then as far back as the Egyptian times, what they would use to represent a was like
a bull or an ox head.
No, that totally makes sense.
I mean, I think when you say the three hundreds, you mean like maybe the three hundreds BC, because
you know, but we get our, our characters from Roman times.
Like I, I learned this by playing, uh, uh, expeditions Rome mostly, uh, which is a great RPG.
Uh, the great thought though.
You are right. 300 BC, uh, maybe even a little earlier to be honest, cause the Greek alphabet, obviously
uh, the one that is close to what we have today as well.
Uh, that also has the A as we understand it today.
Yeah. Alpha.
Yeah. Like the, like the show.
Yes. Um, and you know, another thing about the letter A that you might not know is that it's a vowel.
Love. Yeah. See, I was always proud of knowing that knowledge because like, you know, I'm, I'm not around
a lot of people that are like super well read.
I come from a very like athletic world.
So I, you know, I, I, I'm not the athletic one.
I'm more of the, uh, the guy who knows about vowels.
Yeah. Like your athletic friends might be playing football or mad.
Yeah. Ten yard fight.
Yeah. Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa. Not 10 yard.
No, not 10 yard fight.
Okay. No, no, no.
Yeah. I was always playing like Sesame street, ABC and stuff like that.
Or alien isolation.
You know, like games like that.
The games like that are cool because like you, they have these a, a eyes where they kind
of sound like they're, they're actually present with you because what's up just to get back
on topic for a second.
Um, what do you think about those a's that have like, uh, things are on top of them or
around them? Like those silly a's, you know, that have like an umlaut.
Yeah. All those, uh, or those degrees symbols and a top of them.
Like, what are they doing? They're so silly.
Mike, Sean, can we not kid ourselves?
I don't have to say anymore. You know, yeah, this Wikipedia article is pretty short.
Uh, so I, I was planning on moving into the essential alphabet list in like a second,
but what's your concern?
Joe, I think you, you've got an idea.
Oh, I mean, I was just going to say, cause you mentioned the like degree symbol above
and you know, I, if there's one after 720, 720 degrees on the NES, the skateboarding
game, uh, I don't see why an A couldn't have one, but, but it seems like, um, I don't
know Sean maybe has some more, uh, in depth thoughts.
Do you guys realize what's happening?
No. We have played so many NES games for so many years that even when we try to have conversations
without video games or without nostalgia, it still finds its way into our lives.
It's not the alphabet that you learn.
It's the games you play along the way.
Wow. That is beautiful.
And I think I'm worried that I'm getting nostalgic about nostalgia.
Maybe we should go back on that decision.
Maybe the decision that you forced upon us that we didn't actually have a hand in.
Maybe we should keep playing NES games and record the podcast as usual.
Hmm. That's a bold, uh, idea for a podcast to just all of a sudden keep going the same way it's
been going. So what are we supposed to do?
Just release episodes every Friday for infinity?
Infinity. For infinity.
Yeah, infinity. See, we should do it.
We should actually study these letters though.
Yeah. But on our own time.
Yeah, Mike, please continue to go through this.
Get a better handle of etymology.
Um, I will, I will be with you in spirit.
Yeah. Maybe we do this off.
We, all three of us, we can get together once a week, discuss the alphabet off the microphone
and we'll continue doing, yeah, yeah.
Maybe live shows, but we can continue doing the recorded, uh, stuff as, as is.
I, I like what you're saying, Joe.
You're right. Maybe all these other crazy experiments that we've been trying are just that experiments.
But in the end, nostalgia is a, is a show that is a chronological exploration of every NES
game only released in North America.
Correct. That's why I keep saying that every time at the beginning of the episode.
Oh, I never got that before.
Right. That's what it's about.
Sean. Hey, Mike.
I also don't know what to say here.
I think we just ended there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Don't worry.
Okay. Thank you guys so much for listening to the episode.
As you can tell, nostalgia is going to continue.
So join us for 500 more years of nostalgia, nostalgia, virtual-stalgia.
Uh, actually we wouldn't do the virtual boy, right?
That's a handheld. No, I can't do that, man.
Yeah. Yeah, so we would just go to 64-stalgia.
All right, yeah. We'll do that.
All right, so we'll do that.
And, um, wow, you guys have a lot of patience.
You're just gonna sit here and listen to the gaps.
Should we, like, put, like, a code word at the end here to be like, if you really listened
all the way to the end, we'll bury it a little bit?
Like, the code word, like, tweet at us or something?
Yeah, I mean, yeah, exactly.
If they really listened to the end of this, then they would know to tweet at us what we
said at the 42-minute mark in the Super Mario Bros.
2 episode. Wow.
That's asking a lot.
Um, if you did listen to this part, just tweet, um, Jambalaya.
Zelda 2 is a special game. No.
Stop it, Joe.
Oh, wait, yeah. That's another thing.
Wait, did that happen?
Did that part happen?
No. Yes.
We're on the same page.
It's true.
All of it.
Is that a modern Star Wars reference at the end there?
Oh my god.
You